[Music]
noah
is with us in phoenix arizona hi noah
welcome to the ramsay show dr john
deloney is my co-host today how can we
help
hey there dave thanks for taking my call
sure um
hey uh so uh i um
my family my parents helped me out we
actually just moved down from washington
about seven months ago eight months ago
and um
my family helped me buy a house in um in
arizona and
housing markets so much cheaper here um
so
uh i uh they actually recently just
decided to
purchase they also purchased a house
down here and so they also recently just
decided to
build a new house in the same city and
so they're going to be
they actually co-signed with me for this
house that they help me buy
and they want to refinance to get the
house off their um
sorry to get the loan off their off
their their back so then um it'll just
be on my name and then they can have
more room for
whatever they're doing um i'm curious if
i should
possibly sell the house or
like when we refinance because the house
has already made a bunch of positive
equity
or if i should uh refinance like they
say
how old are you i'm 25.
and you said we are you married uh i'm
no i'm
i'm sorry i'm not it's just me no okay
all right and so you
you bought a house and how much do you
owe on the house
uh i actually it's about two 247 so 247
thousand
okay and what do you make um
so i did the math here um i
actually have renters i have i live in
the house i live in one of the rooms um
two of the renters also live in now i'm
not counting the renters what is your
income sir
oh without the renters it's uh it's
about it's only oh
after tax taxes about 33 000 before
taxes about 39
000. what do you do for a little bit
with renters it's about 46 000. after
that
let me help you with this you make 33
000 a year you can't afford a 250 000
house
you can't afford you can't afford the
house
you can't refinance it you won't qualify
for the loan
you understand yeah i get you not even
close
when you make forty thousand dollars a
year you cannot qualify for a two
hundred fifty thousand dollar mortgage
got it because the payment is as much as
you make man
well but yet it it is and um
and i've and i i checked it out so where
if i did not have renters i would
and i'm already um if i did not have
renters i would be paying
i would be breaking about even but
because i have renters i'm
i'm also paying for college on on top of
this about it's about yeah but the
mortgage company when you go to
refinance will not qualify you based on
renters
they will not use they will not use you
renting out the bedroom as a way to
pay your bill when your payment is equal
to your income
i would sell the house and take equity
and pay for college
yeah you need to sell the house and go
rent something really cheap yourself
and finish up college and get your
income up and then talk about buying
later
and this is going to be a hard
conversation because your parents
probably gave you some stuff
your parents are out of their dadgum
minds yeah
to put you in this mess to start with to
have assisted you to get into this trap
i mean dude if your roommates don't pay
one month
you don't even eat if you pay your house
payment
this is this is cray cray these this
mathematics
math on this is nuts so yeah you
you have really stepped deep into a hole
here
and even for them to have to get off of
a cosine so that they can
buy a second house and build it versus
the they're playing a shield game too
man yeah they're
it sounds like they're in a mess
themselves but that's that's another
story
but yeah for you you're 25 years old
you're going to college
you're making 35 000 39 000 a year
you know sell the house get the equity
pay for your college cash
and make sure you're debt free stay debt
free
do everything you can to get your income
up be studying something in college that
causes your
income income to go up uh don't study
some
left-handed puppetry degree when you
have a when you have kids
you can buy them a house outright not
just co-sign for them
good grief man later on but yeah mom and
dad love you thank you
no because you can't refinance it
even if you want to no mortgage company
is going to give you this loan
and they shouldn't because you can't pay
it